well hello there reject nation I'm Greg
Alva I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
the trailer today because the power went
out all day and we finally just got it
back on we went to go watch Kingsman the
Secret Service review will be up on
Monday that Gordo the Golden Circle
secrets yeah we finally watched the
first one we have an embargo I wasn't
really hiding spine real organization
aboard I'll be up on Monday after the
embargo lifts now that we have power
back and we just got back from the event
haha red Sparrow Jennifer Lawrence yeah
I don't know much about this let's do it
red color she's nervous so she's
drinking
[Music]
young officers trait is juice
manipulated so understand to use it
bodies use everything
[Music]
sparrows this was he atomic blonde black
in some ways I feel like that is the
coolest Black Widow movie that could
possibly ever have and maybe a better
atomic blonder wouldn't have pegged it
for a J law flick but you know what I
just look pretty cool to me this is
interesting to me because Jennifer
Lawrence became superstar from The
Hunger Games which in a lot of ways you
know like how we've been talking about
how a lot of times actresses suddenly
have their like action hero time you
know there's been Scarlett Johansson's
action hero time and then Charlize
Theron czar having her so it's in the
men Jennifer Lawrence even though she
had the hungry after this is from the
director of catching a fire in the
Mockingjay films we've never really
perceived her as an action hero somehow
I feel like if this is a hit because you
don't get a lot of action in it that's
what I like though it feels more like a
spy thriller as opposed to a spy action
movie I feel like that's a weird edge
that a lot of her performances wound up
having is like this is technically kind
of an action movie but we're gonna make
her edge be like in The Hunger Games
like she's really resourceful she is
good with a bow and arrow it's not like
she goes around like cooking fools
yeah yeah x-men you know she like fights
a couple people for one of those movies
focus more on her life and then visit
looks like you know yeah she can kill
people but she's also gonna be like a
really cold detached seductress person I
feel like that's a cool role for her
totally I think like this could be a
really badass role for her I think
Catching Fire I'm a big fan of
Mockingjay part 1 and part 2 movies like
Catching Fire is my favorite one out of
The Hunger Games and it's from the same
director I think this could be a really
neat film I like Joel Edgerton you know
it's great any suits have good judgement
he does and Jennifer Lawrence
I like the specific the specificity
Vicki it's funny cuz you just said it
right
you know other times you do not like a
substance action female spy and that
they make sexy and it's like why yeah I
love how this seemed to like have it be
so intentional oh yeah like it's like
even I mean when the main weapon is your
sexuality and I'm like move excited you
Jennifer Lawrence be sexy yeah yeah like
that we've progressed so quickly from I
hope like my best aspirations for this
movie and it's still you know directed
by a dude so I don't know I'm curious
this seems like a new area of you know
the women kicking ass like action like
we cast an actress we love to kick ass
on down except this one yeah is gonna
really play up the the strange sexuality
of it all that's a conversation I'm
excited to see if natasha romanoff movie
was made it was good yeah yeah like I
feel like if you're really gonna make a
movie about him like this looks likely
with Russian - yeah yeah yeah yeah sucks
to be Marvel cuz they're gonna do it
yeah and I love the sort of like slow-mo
clock ticking while she's waiting in the
room and then just like yeah and on the
hand
oh yeah this was like a tension thriller
yeah yeah and it really capitalized on
like cold impersonal but also like hyper
sexual nature of it or not like yeah
let's go there yeah this is cool if
anything you could probably be
borderline Harthouse action borderline
very yeah careful insane yeah you know
the thing is like this is a very
provocative idea but you know it also
it's a it's written by a dude and
directed by a dude - I want to see how
well it explores this I'm sorry patty
Jenkins can't direct everything yeah the
only time Jenkins Elbe and Lincoln
Kathryn Bigelow yeah
and now one kid frustrated things the
only actors interaction you know
especially coming off of a cure for
wellness and some of the other movies
that dude roll a rioter you know I use
don't feel like that dude has a lot of
good ideas and has only nailed like one
movie for me that was I thought was
pretty great and so like I
that can't happen again I don't pay
attention anymore to win like these big
Hollywood screenwriters unless they're
like Aaron Sorkin script I feel like a
lot of times these big screen these
stream writers who did those they could
write any genre but at the end of the
day it just changes from studios and
directors perspective oh yeah like I
can't I don't really know what this
dude's material actually is he wrote
Revolutionary Road in the low range
yeah like the more I think about writing
especially hearing that Joss Whedon news
and stuff like that and and you know
hearing from people who've done punch up
and all kinds of things over the years I
am like yeah like what does it mean to
be a writer in Hollywood unless you're
like Charlie Kaufman no idea Hey Kaufman
which company do the Kaufman Charlie
Kaufman is the alive one or Andy Kaufman
is the dead anyway guys yeah that's a
cool trailer man that was actually a
nice surprise I thought it might have
just turn to some action crap yeah I was
gonna be coming are you excited to see
Jennifer Lawrence and this spy thriller
would you prefer this to be the Natasha
Roman Huff's solo movies put your
comments below subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification bell -
on Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram and
check out our patreon become a patron
ejecta die yeah